[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we were joking about how you could dance
to the end of the day leafy music no be
very fun if there was like a flash mob
that suddenly hello London
thank you so much we are here for our
first international event and we are
thrilled we are completely thrilled and
what you just heard is a classic like in
the life of the daily it is baffling it
is relentless and it is disrupted by
Donald Trump yes that's the story of our
lives for the past two years
I am Michael barber oh I'm the host of
the daily and I'm Theo Balcom and I'm
the executive producer of the show
Theo was the first employee of the daily
yeah you hear those credits you've heard
her name from day one she makes this
thing you love
Thank You fear yes and as I said we're
here for the first time finally Michael
and I got to get out of the studio yeah
leave the cage the cage we really never
had any idea when we started the show
that there would even be this many
people listening to what we made so the
fact that you do listen and you're all
here it's extraordinary really exciting
yeah so we wanted to tonight talk a
little bit about why we're here is
making this our first international yes
and that is because of the tremendous
mess you've made of Europe and we knew
we wanted to come and tell the story of
the EU in this moment and we've been
wanting frankly to tell that story for
some time we finally had the bandwidth
to do it and that's what we're gonna be
talking about tonight we're gonna be
talk about the state of the EU populism
and nationalism in the European Union
but before we get to that we want to
spend a little bit of time talking to
you all about the story of the daily
right where we have come from and and
what we are and why we are yeah because
I think if you guys found out where we
came from you would be shocked that so
we started the show with three producers
I came from National Public Radio woman
named Lisa Tobin who
the head of our audio team and then
another producer Andy Mills from Radio
lab a show at WNYC if you are familiar
with that we were the three producers
that started the show and then we had a
host who knew nothing about audio
nothing nothing with audio and I want to
talk about that but first I want to show
you what it looked like when the four of
us started making the daily so we were
we were literally in a storage closet
this is only kind of space the New York
Times gave us yeah now now they say
they're really proud of the daily the
flagship audio show but this is how they
treated us at the beginning we we had a
utility closet on the 16th floor of the
times that had previously been used for
rubbish and also had been used for a
computer that contained all the leaked
documents from WikiLeaks that had no
internet connection it was like a bunker
so you can see there's a there's some
foam walling around and and this is
where we spent 24 hours a day creating
the show and Thea wasn't joking when she
said that I knew nothing about audio
yeah I had been a print reporter at the
times for a decade and I had not so much
as listen to maybe I'd listen to one or
two podcasts right when you all asked me
to host the day right inspired a lot of
confidence right yeah and so the
question was sort of like what do we do
with this guy he has a lot of
relationships around the newsroom yep he
can help us land interviews yep I think
the big question mark was kind of what I
would sound like right so so Michael
would kind of go into an interview in
the early days and he would ask a good
question and then the guest might say
something and it might be kind of funny
or it might be kind of heartwarming or
it might be kind of interesting and a
typical person if you're having a
conversation would sort of react right
Michael would just sit there say nothing
so the initial notes were like you know
if something's funny Michael you could
go ahead and laugh that would be a good
idea yeah that'd be a great idea it
turns out if you don't laugh an audio
then the audience doesn't know that
they're supposed to laugh and so
wah-ha-ha-ha great and that's also how
we got to like people comment all the
time if they're diehard listeners of the
show maybe some of you experienced
this the from from our fair host that
all came about because we were like you
need to be in the conversation you need
to be responding and that and that and
that was the sort of real thing I did as
a print reporter but it suddenly
translated to audio but what didn't
translate was the sudden need at the
beginning of the show and at the end of
the show to to actually recite words
that were written on a page right at the
beginning of the show and I really
really struggled with that because there
was this kind of intangible sense I
wasn't doing it right and we're gonna
show you what that sounds like all right
we're ready we're gonna start tracking
if we lose something we'll start up
again you've never watched me track it's
painful I feel I'm feeling very seen
it's Wednesday February 1st it's
Wednesday February 1st it's it's
Wednesday February 1st what's the matter
I'm not hitting Wednesday right I know I
just these directions are not meaning a
lot to me
it's Wednesday it's Wednesday February
1st there you go I still like that
Arizona's [ __ ] right now we got a
[ __ ] narrate it's ap munches anything
I have to say as a show that was also
cut down a lot for the record I just
want to say I really do think the first
Wednesday was fine okay so the other
thing you should know about the daily is
that besides a host who had no idea what
he was doing at the beginning we had a
show without an identity and it took us
it took us about a month to figure out
we wanted to call yeah it was really
hard to find a name names are hard names
are really hard everybody thinks they
have a great idea for how to name a
podcast and it always begins with the
AHA and so we sat in the room we came up
with a lot of does the story the
briefing the lead the lead was
unfortunately a CNN show yeah so we
cancelled that so then we then we
settled on the name
of the show that we absolutely loved and
we even came up with iconography for it
and I want to show you that for whatever
reason we were in love with this bird
the bird yeah so first stop was gonna be
a huge hit and first off was gonna wake
you up in the morning with a chirping
bird in your head and this yellow bird
became so beloved on the daily and we
shared this with people all over the
company and they got excited about it
and then the last minute the executive
producer of New York Times audio she
just woke up with this epiphany that
this was all wrong and if the show
needed to be called what we called it
internally as a prototype as a pilot
just the daily the thing we make every
day and when she made that decision
she said well we're gonna take the bird
with us and the marketing people said if
the name dies the bird dies and so the
bird died and we had a huge fight with
them and and and so instead you now know
what we have we have the gradient the
the the sunrise the the gay pride flag
it's sort of it's whatever y'all in
there whatever you need it to be yeah so
we went through lots of iterations of
what we were gonna call it how Michael
was gonna say the date you know there's
so many things that you have to figure
out and it really at that time the idea
that the New York Times was gonna make
an audio show was just a very bizarre
concept right
what is this newspaper doing getting
into podcasts and so we had a lot of
thoughts about what that actually might
mean like what is the show actually
gonna sound like at the end of the day
should it be more formal right after all
this is the all the news that's fit to
print the August New York Times right
we'd be delivering the news the way in
audio the way we kind of deliver it in
print with all this kind of authority
right or did we want it to be more
informal and we kind of got a test of
this very early on if you listen to this
next clip we're going to play which is
from the very first episode of the show
day one
hello mr. green it's Michael Barbaro
from New York Times how are you yeah go
ahead how can I help you
so David Green if the name doesn't ring
a bell to you because you don't live the
United States
is that he's the founder of Hobby Lobby
which is the at the center of a major
United States Supreme Court case over
contraception and whether or not
companies can opt out of the United
States Affordable Care Act's mandate
around providing contraception and in
particular the morning-after pill and he
wanted to come talk to us about Donald
Trump's choice for their Supreme Court
nominee which was being announced the
next day because if you remember there
was a sort of crazy night where the
president was going to announce one
justice that he was gonna nominate the
Supreme Court but he had set it up in a
sort of the bachelor style so he had two
different nominees right and he was
gonna pick one so he ends up giving the
rose to the old Gorsuch Al Gore such
right and David Green is a big fan of
Neil Gorsuch because Neil core such
endorsed his decision not to provide
this contraceptive so so we call him up
and the conversation got pretty heated
the liberal press will never say this
they will never say that we offered 16
different contraceptives and I don't see
you doing it that way you guys won't
write because it doesn't fit your
narrative does it well the beauty of
audio is that you're saying it and our
listeners are hearing it so this moment
yeah it was kind of intuitive it's like
but the reality is in as a print
reporter you would never run that you
don't run people sticking their middle
finger up at you you know as you don't
say in the story that you know David
Green who told us he didn't trust us
said quote don't do that right even in a
radio interview like that would be that
one of the first things to go you know
you're questioning our authority you're
kind of right take it you're building
your interview evocative
and instead we made a decision as a
group remember this is day one so we
don't really yet know what the show is
that we were going to keep this in the
episode and it very quickly became a
kind of manifesto yeah that here was a
guest who told us on day one that he
didn't trust us to tell his story and we
trusted the listener to hear that absorb
it and make a decision about whether or
not we'd given him a fair shot and I
think because we had just come out of
the 2016 election in the US and because
a lot of our kind of confidence in
ourselves had been kind of shaken by
that election we were if we were being
honest in a period of reckoning around
what we had done right and what we had
done wrong in that election
we felt that moments like this were kind
of corrective to that that if we let
people challenge us and if we were
transparent with a listener and we let
you see into our process and understand
how we make decisions then you would
trust us more right so this became a
real model for us as we went on to let
you all into the reporting process to
understand what happens when we call
sources to understand what happens when
we call reporters and how they get the
stories that they get and so that was
day one there were many more days after
that and one of the next moments that
really felt important to us was when the
New York Times as it does had a giant
scoop a breaking story this was around
of course President Trump and Russia and
what happened was that the president had
fired his FBI director and that part
everyone understood our colleague Mike
Schmidt had broken the story that before
that had happened the president had
invited the FBI director to dinner and
requested his loyalty over dinner
and of course didn't quite get it right
and we had to understand what this story
was right it was the most important
thing going we needed to talk to Schmidt
because he was the person who knew what
had happened he was kind of the only one
so we said okay Mike can we get you on
the show and it got a little complicated
hey hey sorry thank God the folks here
let me use the phone how did you do that
I told them I needed to call the office
but the problem is I got my laptop on
the other side of Kinkos here I'm afraid
some Russian spies gonna take it so I
gotta keep my eyes on it Michael Schmidt
called us from the only landline he
could find so Mike what did you find
so koma gets fired on Tuesday I go in
the office 7:00 a.m. on Wednesday
morning we're just trying to figure out
what the heck happened and start making
some calls early so Mike could only talk
to us from the Kinkos in middle of
nowhere I don't know
Chicago's I wouldn't let us say it first
because he was on super-secret reporting
trip but it was moments like this that
as Theo says you would immediately cut
from your work at National Public Radio
I mean yeah
also you wouldn't you once joke that you
would never have aired that interview oh
it's a terrible phone line can you
imagine hearing that on the BBC like an
actual reputable broadcast like nobody
would air that but so we liked being
disreputable and and sort of letting you
meet a reporter like Mike exactly as he
is right is such a character right this
kind of swaggering reporter it's like he
doesn't quite have a gun slung to his
side but like but when you listen to the
daily enough you kind of imagine like a
pen is holstered and and this episode
was a breakthrough for us because it was
such a compelling story and it was told
so compellingly from the middle of a
Kinkos right and does anyone know what
Kinkos is by the way incas is a
now-defunct brand name of a yeah of a
store where you would go in the United
States to take to make copies of things
at a stage and our history ox machine
need to go here like but that doesn't
exist anymore
but it did a couple years ago yeah so
anyway so we make this part of the story
that we tell and and we ended the
interview like this Mike thank you very
much and please thank Josh I was gonna
kill me here he wants me to go the folks
they can't goes Joshua thank you very
much you didn't rain all right
by Mike thanks and so now everybody like
isn't in love with Joshua
you know except his bosses yeah that's
part of the story our understanding he
did not get in trouble no I hope not
so today the daily is not in that tiny
room anymore we we have a set of studios
proper studios don't do bad phone lines
anymore as much we're on the third floor
of The Times building with the rest of
the news room we have been integrated
and shown the proper regard and and now
we look like this and now we look like
this we are a team of almost 20 people
that's because of the size we're able to
do things like leave New York leave New
York come to London come to London and
make a very special series of stories
which we are going to tell you about in
just a moment so here to discuss what is
about to be a remarkable and really
unusual run of of coverage that we're
gonna do are three people who've been
intimately involved in thinking about
Europe thinking about you thinking about
this mess you've made and how it's going
to get cleaned up and that is our Berlin
bureau chief catch and Ben hold
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi no we're gonna do such formal
greetings we have our London
corresponding has been covering
breakfast at Allen berry
[Applause]
[Music]
and we have daily producer
extraordinaire Claire tennis getter
thia was gonna briefly leave us but
don't worry she's gonna come back so
thank you all for making time for us
before we start this discussion we are
gonna play a clip from this five days of
daily episodes are gonna start to air
next week that and I think you'll get a
feel for kind of what we're up to funny
isn't it isn't it funny you know when I
came here 17 years ago and I said that I
wanted to lead a campaign to get Britain
to leave the European Union you all
laughed at me well I have to say you're
not laughing now are you
[Applause]
I'll make one prediction this morning
the United Kingdom will not be the last
member state to leave the European Union
from the New York Times
I'm Michael Bavaro this week on The
Daily US the European citizens we are
living in a bubble before the recent
rise of nationalism in the United States
in Europe a decades-long plan to stitch
together countries and cultures into a
united Europe was ultimately blamed for
two crises the UN estimates about 5,700
migrants have arrived in Italy from
Tunisia since January 1 of mass
migration into Europe is a big problem
there too much of them the other of
crippling debt a lot of Italians that
want to leave the euro
yes together they set off Europe's own
wave of nationalism we've had enough we
don't want to be governed by you we want
to govern ourselves while the UK has
elected to leave the EU altogether
nationalist movements across the rest of
Europe want to blow it up from within
it's Monday June 10
it's almost Monday June 10 I think that
sounded that one sounded better right
that one sounded fine
yeah our secret is out a little bit in
that we we we do record episodes ahead
of a time sometimes we like the error
where everyone thought we made the show
between midnight and 5:00 a.m. but that
actually never existed but don't tell
anybody that so Katherine I want to
start with you because you have just
finished this I think it was nine days
straight of reporting with Claire as you
guys tried to kind of impossibly
ambitiously figure out the story of
what's happening in Europe right now and
in a way you kind of embody Europe
yourself to an unexpected degree and I
want you to talk a little bit about your
background and how you fit into this yes
so I I'm German originally but I would
say I feel European first and I think in
this country that probably makes me a
citizen of nowhere or I think Teresa may
what'd she call us cute jumpers that's
me
so and but seriously I mean Europe for
me has always been kind of the story of
my life it's sort of my own family it's
kind of a product of Europe so I was
born in Germany I ended up going to
Britain to university because I could
because the EU allowed me to go to
university anywhere in the EU and it was
actually for free at the time and you
know as a bonus I actually met my future
husband at university he here's a
Welshman and you know our two
grandparents our two grandfathers had
fought on opposite sides of the war and
his grandfather was actually a prisoner
of war in Germany his grandmother
reminded me of this quite a lot how
early on what's that how early on how
early on in the relationship oh my god
this was this is the moment first time I
met my husband's grandmother this was
like she had this thing with partners of
her grandchildren she had like this
categorization between specials and
floozies
I was still in the floozy stage so this
was important and we had lunch at her
lake she's like it's offices widow in
Kent like very portion you know I her in
this house the old rectory and I was
super nervous more nervous than tonight
and the first question she asked me when
we sat down to lunch was like oh so you
from Germany I can't do the accent so
you're from Germany my husband was a
prisoner of war in salad do you know
sell it so that's that story did you get
married though yeah yeah it took a few
more years eventually I did become a
special but yes so we now have three
children my husband and I and they are
basically speaking out two languages
they feel equally at home in our two
countries they're basically little
European so for my children Europe is
just a fact of life and I remember
trying to explain brexit to my
seven-year-old daughter a couple of
years ago and we're still living in
London I was a correspondent here and I
sort of explained to her that there were
some Brits who wanted to leave Europe
and she looked at me in utter
astonishment and said where do they want
to go Africa so yeah and what did you
respond I I was sort of lost for words
but I found that it sort of summed up
the absurdity of the situation for her
in that moment brilliantly I feel like
the one thing that occurs to me is you
tell your biography is that you're
you're also German so you want something
you understand something very profound
about the roots of the EU in this moment
yeah I mean the EU was basically born in
this moment of you know after this
terrible war and after the Holocaust you
know in the 40s and 50s people sort of
stuck their heads together and decided
this can't happen again so that's kind
of the you know the early promise of the
EU was peace and prosperity
connectedness yeah this idea that you
know we got it just sort of suppressed
nationalism this nationalism that has
been feeling ethnic hatred and fueling
war ultimately and you know this was the
idea to do it to get so sort of
collective and intertwined that war
became unthinkable and so
in a way today seeing the reemergence of
that nationalism was a reason for me to
sort of say look we got to check in with
people and see what Europe means to them
today what does it mean today it used to
mean this thing and in some parts of
Europe particularly where I'm from in
western Germany this promise was pretty
much kept right I mean for Germany the
EU was kind of rehabilitation and gave
Germany a positive identity and a
massive export market on top of that so
what's not to like
but you know the idea was to sort of go
beyond that and sort of go dig deeper
into the countries where all this sort
of nationalism is rising now and just
really hear people's stories hear what
they have to say and you get paired with
two producers one of whom is not here
Lindsey garrison one of whom is very
much here Clare tennis getter and so how
did you guys start to logistically
figure out something as complicated as
telling the story of Europe in nine days
well I knew that I wanted to talk to
Katrin and just do a story on the AFT
the far-right party in Germany so for a
couple years now I've been calling you
every other month and stalking me on the
phone yeah I know I would go on our
little computer system and I would find
a story she's working on it collar and
say I see you have this this interview
do you think you could make that into a
daily episode but nothing worked nothing
worked and then finally we have a call
and you say well that's go on this big
trip I'm about to go to five country and
she's like can I come and I'm like okay
and she said can it bring Lindsey as
well I'm like okay and then I said how
long are you planning this five country
trip for oh yeah I know it's like five
days I said I don't think we'll be well
I need a few more for audio and we
settled on about nine I think you guys
feel like can we do like two to three
weeks and I'm like no because the
election is actually going to happen
before then and they're like oh okay why
is five days not enough for audio so an
audio you really need to get to know
characters you need to just gather so
much tape we're just we're rolling all
the time recording from the minute we
wake up and so
like meet me at 4 a.m. at Tegel Airport
and we'll start the trip and they're
like yeah they're like and if you see us
before you're through the security don't
talk to us pretend you haven't seen us
because we have to actually record that
first moment I'm like what and she's
like yeah we're gonna start rolling and
recording you basically at 4:30 in the
morning is that okay and I'm like what
are you gonna ask me and they're like oh
you know why are we going to Strasburg
first what are you looking to find on
this trip what does nationalism mean I'm
like holy [ __ ] so I'm like you know I
didn't tell this to them until the very
last day
yeah the last day I was like you know
what I scripted the answers out to those
11 p.m. the night before I was like what
am I gonna say at 4:00 in the morning to
these so I was like learning this stuff
by heart and but then I realized it's
totally hopeless because they they roll
like 24/7 and one of the reasons we do
is because we want these very natural
moments so these scripted answers
actually can't sound that great and make
it make the tape because she had kind of
memorized them and what we want I've
just these really human natural moments
and I have one more funny story about
that first morning oh my god so Lindsey
and I woke up 4:00 a.m. to go to the
Berlin Airport it's actually yeah the
first time I'm meeting capture in person
and and we start recording from the
moment our alarm clocks go off actually
we hit record before we even shut off
our alarms because we want those little
moments we want the alarm we want the
door closing and the taxi cab why why do
you want those so much we want to show
the motion we want we want you to feel
like as you're listening you're there
with us you're traveling from point
eight you were in a dead weight clear as
the alarm clock is on you hear me brush
my cheese and pack my suitcase so
Lindsey and I we recorded every moment
we get to the airport we're about to go
through airport security and she turns
to me and she says do you think I should
stop it or just roll through I'm the
more like responsible she's the more
creative and I was like turn it off
there you're gonna get in trouble but of
course she's like no no it'll be really
good audio with the beeps if it
successfully goes through so she leaves
it running immediately the airport
security man in Berlin picks it up and
it hits this on and says you need to
delete this right now because no we've
had with two hours we need these little
moments you're gonna ruin our audio
documentary and she charmed him and
eventually she went into a tiny room and
I immediately grabbed my bags and it
went away it was like don't delete my
files too but she ended up getting to
keep it and we can use those all those
moments the moment that we met Katrin
yeah and that is how the daily was
detained in Berlin it was almost the end
of the trip so as you guys start and
you're rolling in bathrooms and bedrooms
and and all the rest what was the first
stop and how did you envision the trip
going so the idea was kind of to start
where Europe started this is on the
french-german border you know these sort
of arch enemies that had sort of been
fighting for centuries and it was
interesting because it was kind of the
one place where we still found kind of
unfettered idealism for the EU a lot of
people spoke to us about a United States
of Europe and I'm not just talking about
professors and sort of educated types
but like you know an electrician a
carpenter I mean working-class people
whose families had experienced in this
region which had changed between france
and germany like six times you know in
since the 17th century you know who we
met I met this priest who like whose
grandfather had fought for the French
and World War one and then it fought his
father had fought for the Germans in
World War two I mean he says sort of
this is a crazy region I mean they'd
sort of joke about keeping German
street signs in the basement just in
case
[Laughter]
but you know if you think of the EU as
something but if you think of the
foundation of the EU as kind of the
memory of war you know we're sort of in
trouble because that memory is fading
right now and this was the one place
where that memory still felt very alive
and the EU was something very concrete
because that border now that you know
these people used to die over is
basically non-existent people live on
one side of the border and go to work on
the other so that was our starting point
but we then pushed into France because
in France as you know there's this
yellow vest movement which has been
making headlines and has been
challenging this young dynamic president
who only a couple of years ago was
supposed to be the savior of France and
of Europe and is now really hated we
discovered we you know yellow vest
movement was one stop and then we pushed
into Italy because we felt that while in
France this movement was challenging the
government was still just a leaderless
sort of chaotic movement in Italy you
have a situation where this nationalist
hard right movement the League of Matteo
salvini
is already in government and still just
as a coalition partner but it's rising
fast and a lot of people think he will
probably be the future Prime Minister
moving on from Italy into Poland which
is sort of the represents it's the
largest country of the latest group of
joiners after the Cold War and here you
have a Nationalist government that has
been in power since 2015 and had a
majority and has had the power to really
attack democratic institutions so we
wanted to see this arc and basically see
what happens as the far right and as
nationalists gain power you keep using
this word nationalism and as I prepared
for this interview I kept wondering what
the difference is and Alan I'm
interested in what you think about this
as well what is the difference between
nationalism which we now talk about with
lots of alarm versus patriotism which is
something we talked about with reverence
you know an affection and love for your
country and where do you see the line
between the two as you're as you're
starting this trip so I probably started
out having a similar feeling broadly
speaking about nationalism to spending
something bad I mean I'm from
and certainly as I grew up I mean I
barely saw the German flag because it
was kind of a taboo and when I did see
it I thought that's probably a Nazi I
mean it was like really like that and
people didn't use it no I mean very very
rarely um and as that's that changed and
has gradually changed and under Angela
Merkel and you know because we hosted
that wonderful Soccer World Cup in 2006
it really was a moment and so the sort
of idea of civic patriotism kind of has
emerged and people are now able to use
the flag again but so I thought
distinction so speaks to me but what I
found on this trip is that actually a
lot of the nationalist movements have
caught on to this and if you ask the AFD
in germany today or if you ask the leak
in italy today if they're nationalist
they're like no no we're Patriots
nationalism has a negative connotation
we're Patriots so for me by now I would
say the distinction really ought to be
between ethnic nationalism or patriotism
and civic nationalism or patriotic
forces Civic because everything else is
just terminology and what these people
are doing actively and they will say so
is we occupy language and so they're
claiming patriotism for themselves just
as much as anyone and so I feel like the
the adjective is almost more important
what do you think where does the
patriotism end and the nationalism begin
here ok one thing that has been really
interesting looking at brexit is how
much Englishness is wrapped up in the
brexit project it was not it's not a
British project and people who describe
themselves as English rather than
British are far more likely I think it's
80 85 % more likely to be supporting
brexit so there is a sense of having
lost something lost identity or lost a
claim on the country that that at one
point was secure so I think maybe it's a
sense of loss something haven't been
taken from you mhm and as you travel to
these four countries and you're
identifying what the nationalist
movements look like what are you finding
about them what is what is their kind of
fundamental animating
force and how persuasive are they so I
would say my first observation is that
almost none of the people we spoke to in
these movements actually want to leave
the EU that's just you guys and I think
you may have put them off even the
populace but um almost no one we spoke
to was sort of happy with how the EU
worked I mean one sort of distinction if
you want to it's simplistic but it's
sort of it's true to what we saw is that
we found that a lot of these people
spoke about kind of a fear of a Muslim
invasion this idea of Christian values
suddenly it's become very very important
both in Italy and Poland and we got a
sense that there is almost sort of a
battle of ideas unfolding in Europe
right now between two different visions
of Europe and what are the two visions
one is sort of liberal democracy and
that's the one that sort of has come
under attack right now because it very
much is embodied by the EU and the EU
institutions and when I say level
democracy what exactly do we mean so
liberal democracy is basically the idea
of a pluralistic society it's not just
democracy where a majority sort of makes
decisions for everybody but where
minority rights are protected where you
have an independent judiciary you have a
sort of a free and open society and not
so long ago Western Europe and then
Eastern Europe as it's signed up to
these these conditions and order to
become member of the U these values sort
of reigned but they've really come into
question because they haven't been
delivering to a lot of people this is
something that we found I mean this is
us on the roundabout outside of us in
northern France northwestern France this
is sort of one of the hold out
roundabouts in in this whole yellow vest
movement so we sort of arrived in right
we try to arrange these interviews ahead
of time with people and actually they
didn't want to talk to the press they
weren't interested but we just so showed
up and it was a really interesting
moment because you know you arrive at
this you can see it is a stormy day it's
this sort of muddy intersection a muddy
not grassy knoll on the corner of a big
intersection and you've got this I don't
see them at these big kind of yeah
multinational sort of all around you got
an Ikea you got a Burger King on the
other side and here is the sort of
blazing bonfire and a few kind of
plastic chairs sat around it with people
in their bright yellow reflective vests
just sort of sitting there and basically
trying to bring down this president
which is the basic thing that United
them but also saying democracy is not
working for us a lot of the people we
spoke to had never vote it had never
bothered or some of them had voted for
my call but felt completely betrayed
even a couple of years in so I don't
know if you agree clear but I my sense
was that we a lot of around this trip
you sort of felt that Europe had become
almost like synonymous with these big
abstract things things like liberal
democracy or austerity or wage
stagnation or migration in the case of
Italy so I felt a lot of resentment
certainly yeah I feel like there's
always this moment when you're out doing
interviews about these movements that it
feels to me like the Willy Loman moment
in Death of a Salesman a person who
feels like they're their birthright has
somehow been slipped away from them that
what they thought they were gonna get in
the fullness of their adulthood has been
taken and that's the moment where they
bang on the table or that's the moment
when they say something about who they
are and and that that feeling is kind of
wrapped up in all these movements you
described well good justjust because
what I thought was really interesting on
that round about you can't see it but
behind these chairs is this small wooden
shed and it's a shed that a retired
carpenter ghee whom we'd interviewed at
length on that round one who's been
there pretty much every day since
November 17th at least for a few hours
every day has been built and rebuilt a
couple of times because it's been taken
down by police in between and this shed
to me was fascinating because it was
this like small 7 square meter shelter
that in a way was a microcosm of the
French Way of life that they were trying
to hold on to there was a small bar in
there with coffee sack of potatoes
petanque balls
there was a sofa and there was so much
camaraderie
in about five minutes after this photo
was taken this is mother of all
downpours it was like raining and
storming there was lightning and
everybody sort of crowded into this tiny
shelter cream everyone ran in together
and there actually they had gone out in
the roundabout to give flyers to these
cars to get to get support garner
support for the yellow vest movement
which is which is dying and they're
trying to get work but why is the you a
threat this kind of Museum of French
life is I guess what I'm struggling to
understand why what sir why is the
European Union a threat to this this
kind of little encapsulation of
Frenchness that you're seeing what are
they what are they afraid of they're
telling you we asked them this question
and they basically said that Europe is
synonymous with wage competition the
minute the Eastern European countries
joined they felt that their salary
increases leveled off they felt that
they had to work harder longer hours
more overtime and not get paid for it
because they were subcontractors now
companies from Bulgaria or Poland that
would offer the work more cheaply to the
big companies that they're their own
companies was trying to get contracts
for they really sort of said that that
period between 2004 and 2010 and then of
course the financial crisis made it all
worse they felt a sort of leveling off
in their living standards and a lot of
them are really struggling and and we
saw their paychecks and we saw the sort
of what is left at the end of the months
and it's basically nothing and this sort
of humiliation of having you know being
an electrician in France
second generation your father was an
actress before you but in those days was
able to buy a house when he was thirty
and bring up a family and a kind of semi
middle-class way here you are now in
this generation you can barely pay your
rent you have to ask your father for a
loan when your boiler breaks you have to
tell your children in the middle of the
months that there's not gonna be enough
money until the end of the month you can
never take your children to the cinema
or to Paris and so in this context this
movement started growing and these
people were telling us about the sense
of community and a family on these
roundabouts this guy Jeremy who might
just describe this turn this electrician
he basically said he'd never voted he'd
never
been on a demonstration this is mainly
an apolitical movement if some of them
vote for marine lepen it's because they
want my comb out but he was basically
saying the first time he showed up on
the Mount Rhonda body was sort of like
curious because it was happening in his
city and he saw all these people that he
sort of vaguely knew and then he met
some others and they discovered that
they all had the same problems and what
a relief it was to find this community
and to realize they're not the only ones
so to me that was really really
insightful and also humbling because
let's face it we are all part of a very
privileged elite and things like liberal
democracy and Europe have worked very
nicely for us but you realize when you
travel the lands in Europe today that
there are a lot of people who feel that
liberal democracy is not working for
them what you're describing sounds very
generational I have an image in my head
of older French polish German
complaining of an era that's gone of an
identity that's been robbed of a life
that no longer exists
am I wrong and assuming that so I went
into the story sort of with the same
assumption and it's a it's not a bad
assumption I mean if you look at Britain
if I'm not mistaken um you know the
younger people are more likely to be
against brixon and it's the older people
who've been in favor of it but I was
quite shocked to find that along the way
we met a lot of young people who have
either inherited or just simply embodied
and embraced fairies in a xenophobic
views actually I mean that the one of
the one of the moments that really stuck
with me is meeting this this father and
an engineer in Italy in Tuscany on this
Market Square in a red so somebody who
votes on the center-right he happened to
be there when we were there with this
sort of leak League politician but we
started talking to him and and I sort of
asked him a variation of your question
and he said you know the young people
they really hate the migrants and I was
like whoa what do you mean and he said
he was watching the television news with
his sixteen-year-old daughter just a few
days earlier
and he said they were watching this
report about a migrant ship that had
capsized you know and a hundred migrants
had died and his daughter just gave the
thumbs up and he said he was shocked by
this and he she saw his shock and the
sort of horror in his face and said dad
don't look so shocked everybody thinks
this and you know they sat down for a
long conversation and sort of trained
him and his wife kind of tried to talk
to their daughter about human rights
about difficulty some of these people
have gone through and so on and he said
he believes that that conversation
probably hasn't made a difference the
other small story in that context was
when we were on the plane to Poland and
and just by chance run into the school
class from the Normandy beaches it's
d-day today and it was basically
teenagers aged thirteen fourteen and
they were on an Erasmus program they now
do these four high school students in my
days it was only University but you know
they were going on a one-week exchange
to a Polish and I was talking to the
teacher who would organize this and ask
him so why did you why did you do this
and he said there was this time around
2015 16 when the migrant crisis was
really sort of hot that he started
hearing his students refer to migrants
as rats and other sort of Vernon Vernon
vermin basically and and that they were
applauding the idea of Trump kind of
building a wall and he sort of said in
this region of France in particular you
know how is it possible that they do not
think of their own history and of all of
that and of Europe and of and and he
said their grandparents are even too
young to have experienced World War two
and so they have no conception of
history and of the sort of these kind of
values and so he decided having heard
them talk like this that he needed to
get them into some one of these exchange
programs so who knows what comes out of
it so answer your question I feel that
we cannot rely on the fact that this
phenomenon will just die out with the
older people I feel like there's a young
cohort that is very much in to swept up
in it so I could even see where it could
start to grow and this yellow vest
family that you talked about that didn't
have
anti-migrant feelings they're just a
political this father who is an
electrician and his wife and is these
three kids and but the two parents would
go to this roundabout they said just
about every day and we went over and met
the whole family and talked to their
fourteen-year-old daughter Luna and she
when we asked her do you feel European
you're 14 you can you you've grown up
with nothing but the European Union and
she said what does it mean you're
European and French and then later on in
the conversation we were asking her
about her dreams what she wants to be
when when she grows up and she kind of
seems she had this twinkle in her eyes
when she said that she really hoped to
tour with the animals maybe to be a vet
she had a dog that was running around
the entire time we were interviewing her
but then she she paused and said but
probably I'll just be an electrician
like my dad so you can see that there
wasn't but you know what's interesting
and I just sort of coming off that story
but Franz was very much a sort of I mean
we nobody had anything good to say about
the European Union flat black or you
know that there was no seemed to be very
little about emotional tissue or
whatever with the European Union in what
was interesting then in Poland was that
to us that the European flag has
actually become a symbol of resistance
there where the resistance to what's
that so the pro-democracy movement in
Poland which is sort of pushing back
against the attempts of the nationalist
government to sort of undermine
independent judiciary and like come to
come down hard on on the independent
independent press is flying the European
slack on the streets in protest marches
and this editor of this liberal
newspaper told us that when a
nationalist lawmaker had sort of
referred to the European flag as a rag
he'd gone out and bought one and put it
up outside his house so it's very
interesting the sort of emotions that
are elicited in different parts of
Europe by this European idea of course
you know the other side the nationalists
in Poland have a very different
narrative again their narrative is that
you know Poland fought for independence
Toland toppled communism and now these
Western countries sort of say they won
the Cold War and are telling Poland what
to do and for them they're not going so
far as to say we want to leave the
European Union but they're saying we
want to take the European Union out of
Poland you know we don't want
interference and I want to talk about
what happens when the Nationalists get
to power and they have what seems like a
concrete demand from the people to do
something like leave the EU which is
what's happened here and it doesn't
happen it hasn't happened so what does
that tell us about these movements when
in a way they kind of get what they say
they want right well Britain obviously
doesn't have a nationalist party never
and never has notably and in some ways
this was an experiment in a sort of
stable well-organized system taking on a
populist project and trying to carry it
out in a responsible way and of course
what we have seen now is it's broken the
system I moved here a couple years ago
and I thought I had a good reliable
theoretical framework for Britain based
on my extremely close reading of the
works of Agatha Christie and what I
understood from that is that this was a
small I look where people knew how to
not take up too much space and live in
relative comedy which is punctuated by
the occasional homicide which is then
resolved in an orderly fashion
[Laughter]
compared to America where we like to
break the China this is a country that
has tended to resolve its existential
differences in in a more friendly way so
we had a scorched-earth winner-take-all
civil war that we've never gotten over
but the British conflicts have usually
been solved
with us
not a monarchy not a republic but some
fudge in between the tunes not Catholic
it's not Protestant but again like
something was found and so this was my
this is my thesis and I loved my thesis
I loved it so much I put it in the paper
and my my colleague Stephen Castle who
is better informed on all of these
matters and myself he was like are you
sure you want to put that in the paper
anyway I put it in the paper and the
thesis was called what could be more
British than a compromise everyone hates
yeah so I think we all know how that
turned out oh yes we haven't we haven't
we have an image that indicates this
from this is biographical material I
didn't write this
that is not your handwriting that would
be your child so I was confidently
striding into the fray with my thesis
what could be more British than a
compromise everyone hates and then the
votes started so I covered meaningful
vote one meaningful vote - and my
daughter June who was up in the audience
she was kind of waiting for it to be
over and I had become invested in this
idea that somehow people could be
persuaded to give up their ideal outcome
and find some common ground just to get
it over with and obviously we all know
that's not what happened we have a
situation of such paralysis really the
example of how bonkers this is is that
last night a viable candidate to succeed
to resume proposed getting the Queen out
of her palace to put Parliament into
recess for long enough to finish a No
Deal brexit and when they're talking
about getting the Queen out of her
palace something's definitely wrong but
but did the brexit vote in the end
defuse the nationalism in a way that
maybe doesn't require the last step is
that a possibility so I would say that
it's been the opposite when I go out and
talk to people about this they are no
longer interested in whether brexit is a
good idea they want to know why their
vote is being ignored so that is the
issue that has completely replaced the
question of whether brexit is good for
the country and I think it's gonna take
years to get it out of the system this
is this is very reminiscent actually of
what we heard but this is interesting
cuz I was France correspondent for for
like ten years
and and was there when when there was
this referendum in France on this
European constitutional treaty in 2005
and if you recall that the French voted
no to that and then a couple of years
later some fudge was arranged and pretty
much the heart and soul of that
I was kind of put into this other treaty
that now wasn't put to a referendum and
just passed anyways the Lisbon Treaty
and and and I sort of didn't pay much
attention to it this is like ancient
history as far I'm concerned when we
were there the people on that roundabout
were talking about that they were
talking about how their vote had been
ignored and when we were in Italy people
were like remember Monti during the
financial crisis and then the debt
crisis where basically the European
Union put pressure on Berlusconi to
resign the elected Prime Minister
whatever you think of him and put in
place basically a technocratic
government for two years under Monti
totally undemocratic and and basically
raised taxes lower spending the peace
financial markets so you know again in
Italy was like democracy what democracy
so I felt like it reminded me of braixen
and much as as you heard from my
introduction I mean as much as I took
brexit personal in some ways when I was
living here and much as I sort of inside
of me thought maybe a second referendum
would be a good idea and maybe it will
never happen actually by now I feel like
it's hard to get away with not doing it
and after that vote you know like I mean
I also think people want they're
beginning to want a different kind of a
different flavor of democracy so I mean
in the system right now you have a whole
bunch of well-meaning officials who
believe that they were elected to use
their judgment as they see fit to
protect the interests of the people and
then you have a whole different part of
the government that believes that when
the people make their wish is clear even
if you think it's a bad idea you do it
you have to do it even if it breaks the
china and these are two groups of I
think well-meaning people who are
putting such strain on the system that
it it may change permanently so what's
the flavor of government we might get as
a result of that I mean I think what you
get is alienation I mean people who no
longer I mean we've been going out and
talking to people who are watching this
play out
the sense of kind of disappointment in
British democracy and they they use
those words if people don't believe that
democracy works they're gonna accept
something less or maybe they even want
something more authoritarian and by less
do we mean a thorat Aryan yes I think so
I mean if they're promised something
promised a different system that that
won't make them if they're promised a
different system that will fulfill their
demands well this brings us to kind of
the impossible question of the night I
think which is if the EU is founded on
the principle of liberal democracy as a
fundamental good and people are
questioning whether that functions what
is the state of that institution in
Europe and therefore the idea of the
European Union itself admittedly how
long do I have it so I mean I think it's
interesting we all saw the the European
elections play out and there there's
there's two interpretations of that
result right I mean there is one benign
interpretation which says which says
that the wave of populist nationalist
getting into the European Parliament
wasn't as bad as a lot of people had
predicted and expected and you could you
know take sort of hope from the fact
that in several countries including
Germany the Greens the pro liberal and
Pro Refugee kind of parties gained but
the other interpretation is that if you
take the long view having nationalists
and populist sort of steadily gained
ground and just get entrenched in the
system and sort of rising from 20 to 24
percent or whatever maybe not to 30 but
steadily gaining ground that that is a
movement that is happening and that that
is a movement that is worrying and and
if you had told me for example now
people said in Germany the AFD only got
11 percent but if you had told me 10
years ago that there would be a a
far-right party in parliament and the
biggest opposition party in the country
that would get 11 percent in the
European elections I
been utterly speechless so if you take a
long view something big is happening
what exactly I don't think we'll know
until like 10 15 years from when we look
back I think Europe has sort of turned
into a battleground there is this battle
of ideas and I don't think it's decided
I don't but I think you know I think
liberals have to put up a fight I don't
really see them putting up a fight right
now but they also have to be incredibly
humble because we are hearing from
people that it's not functioning it's
not working and there's almost and we've
heard this in Poland from the
nationalist we're sort of saying
democracy is doing great in Poland thank
you very much it's doing great
in Hungary we're doing what the people
want we're doing what the people elected
us for we have a majority you guys are
just dreaming of majorities I think
democracy in Germany is not looking so
healthy so it's I think it's important
for the liberal democracy side to really
listen deeply and accept the skepticism
well and and analyse sort of where they
may have gone wrong I mean this this
idea of a liberal liberalism comes to
mind this idea that maybe liberals
haven't been tolerant enough of views
that aren't their own and then of course
the bigger and maybe the question that
we found in every single country is this
issue of social injustice and just this
question that the system isn't
delivering so we've talked about
democracy but there's a broader question
about you know our pairing of capitalism
with liberal democracy and the sort of
social divide right now you know there's
big questions out there and at the
moment I'm not seeing a whole lot of
people grappling with them seriously
everybody's sort of defensive and the
and and what we found in in Italy for
example is that even in places where the
league didn't do well all the other
candidates were just referring back to
the leak and salvini they were sort of
arguing against it but they weren't
taking a there's no language for the
future there nobody's selling a positive
vision for the future to vote right now
well well that's not quite true I mean
you know you've got the greens and
you've got these sort of few examples
you've and then you've got this
unorthodox example
like theta tuned back who probably have
done have to have more leadership in
them than a lot of the sort of leading
you know party leaders and they're
people like McCall where like I said
earlier a lot of people thought he's the
guy he will save Europe and he will save
liberal democracy but he hasn't come up
with the sort of innovation and the new
ideas that really tackle these deep
issues I don't think I asked you before
we did this interview where you see the
the greatest leadership right now and I
want you to tell everybody in the
audience what you said I said we're in
non nationalist governance are you
seeing great leadership we're in non
nationalists yeah and I was referring to
Europe but remember what you said
I don't know China you said China oh
well yeah it's true I mean so this it's
it's true that was brilliant comment
that I made earlier and I've already
forgot but it's true I mean we're in
this world where you've got these
nationalists leaders who are we're great
at being leaders by the way right they
have the language and it's not a
language of the future it's more a
language of the past but it's if that's
what people want to hear they want that
past they want to preserve things so
that's sort of you know Trump's language
that's it's the language of salvini it's
the language of the people in Poland of
the law and justice party China is not a
democracy but it has a a project for the
future it has a language for the future
no one knows where it's going and it's
doing pretty well and so the question is
what do those defending liberal
democracy in Europe
wait what language of the future are
they're gonna find I mean this is what
I'm not seeing right now yeah I mean at
the end of daily episodes I always sum
things up so what you're saying is so
what you're I love this you know the
journalists motto first simplified then
exaggerated yes oh you're you're totally
team yep so what you're saying is things
in Europe are so messy that the model is
a communist government in China
[Laughter]
first summarize then exaggerated so I
love it yes so I will just tell you that
even Chancellor Merkel of Germany has
admitted that when you challenge the
Chinese government on human rights and
they shoot back
well we are lifting millions of people
out of poverty in a pretty effective on
a pretty effective schedule we are
working for human rights even she said
it's very hard to not agree with that
so again I don't think the model is
communism by the way I don't think I
mean it's basically authoritarian
capitalism right that's what China's
model is I don't think that's the model
anyone should strive for but I think
it's really interesting to observe that
the effectiveness of government there
what you know the delivery is something
that certainly in our very messy and
paralysed democracies right now I mean
it's it's a threat to our vision of the
future sure and we need to sort this out
well you're gonna pause thank you all
for this conversation and take some
questions from you the audience about
Europe China the New York Times and the
daily and Michael anything you want to
ask no and I really want to thank you
all for this discussion we're gonna been
Pheo back on to the stage and we have
some microphones up in the balconies
that I think you're all gonna queue up
to if you'd like and then we're gonna
have microphones being passed around the
audience for questions so why don't we
start with lucky number two up there oh
why don't we start with lucky number
four thank you for joining us in London
first of all and thank you for
everything you do I think it's amazing
work my question is about anti-european
sentiment and I'm curious in your
conversations with people if you feel
like the number one driver is maybe fear
of a European sort of entity dominating
policy
and like the lack of relationship or if
it's fear of other people around Europe
who are unfamiliar with like immigrants
or potentially economic reasons what do
you think is the number one driver so if
I was to simplify an exaggerated mm-hmm
I would say it's a fear of losing a
familiar way of life and that actually
sums up a lot of the things you touched
on and in different places different
things are important in Poland we found
that values was the sort of driver of
anti-european sentiment there was this
idea that the EU was unchristian it was
sort of somehow morally void and it was
now imposing it's sort of gender madness
and LGBT craziness and all these like
rites and all this stuff on Poland this
Catholic country that wanted to be just
a Catholic Christian country and you
know that sort of idea of a Christian
Europe felt very dominant prominent
there and on the nationalist side in
Italy migration was something that came
up in every single conversation even
though it's no longer a red-hot crisis
at all in terms of the numbers right but
that sort of experience of 2015 and 16
of being on the front line of this and
being like on the Mediterranean and
seeing hundreds of thousands coming
through it's really stuck with people
and it felt like it sort of traumatized
quite a lot of people and again there
was a sense I mean this is changing my
town my city my familiar way of life and
then finally I would say in terms of the
economic factors there is a sense that
Europe is sort of the face of capitalism
Europe is a face of globalization to
Europeans it represents the sort of free
market that has allowed companies to
take advantage of wage competition and
this idea of a race to the bottom so the
bitterness about a Europe that serves
companies and not little people was
voiced a lot and and again this sort of
conflation of the this idea of liberal
elites and European elites that was used
almost synonymous
we heard that so liberalism has become
conflated very much with economic
privilege so I don't know if that
answers your question but I feel it's a
very complicated patchwork but at the
bottom of it all it's just people it's
that it's the lowman moment it's this
idea of losing losing losing what what
you're used to familiar you're familiar
way of life that's insightful thank you
we're gonna go to number the numbers are
throwing us too high just a question
that was asked to be earlier but I
wonder whether you give him more detail
about I appreciate that there's a lack
of leadership on the liberal democracy
side of the equation in Europe but are
there any interesting thinkers who may
be on in a leadership position but are
putting forward interesting new ideas
that maybe we should start to follow
listen to read that's a great question I
mean III think that in civil society
there is a lot of leadership emerging
now and I mean I mentioned great
Attenberg you've all heard of her I
think she has shown amazing leadership
and has really put the climate change
issue on the map in terms of sort of
politics I mean I personally like
Timothy Garton ash as a thinker I think
he's he's very smart on these subjects I
one of the things he said that is really
stuck with me is that you know this is
sort of a time you know so if you think
of liberal democracy as kind of having
this sort of heyday like these 30 years
of incredible expansion between 1974 and
2004 all the indicators show that the
number of liberal democracies just
expanded in the world it's like from the
democratization of Portugal all the way
up to the color revolutions it was just
like more democracy more liberal
democracy no the cold for and that was
the sense of like it can only go in one
direction and it was kind of a
democratic revolution and then it
plateaued and ever since then it's been
going in the other way it's kind of the
counter-revolution and what Timothy
Garton ash that
he says whenever there's a revolution
there's a counter-revolution so we
shouldn't panic and in some ways this
may also be an opportunity because what
we had during the Cold War is this
competition between two systems and in
some ways liberal democracy it paired
with capitalism was tamed by this
standoff with communism which claimed to
be the social system with liked which
gave him any jobs and so on and if you
think back our welfare states were going
strong during those decades and there
has been since the end of the Cold War
and end to that competition and as a
result sort of deregulation and a lot of
like much less regard perhaps for some
of these social justice issues and now
we have competition again we've got a
sort of competition between liberal
democracy and even though it's sort of
an oxymoron a liberal democracy right
Viktor Orban calls his system a liberal
democracy doesn't make sense but it's a
sort of an illiberal modernity a
different of a different system and I
think that competition may just be the
moment to focus minds and it may just be
a moment and again we won't know for a
decade or so to spark some of that
leadership so populism nationalism tames
capitalism and therefore makes a better
liberal democracy potentially yeah I
think I think it focused minds at the
time I mean I remember my mom in West
Germany growing up in the 80s always
saying that you know the GDR East
Germany was sort of the elephant in the
room during these union negotiations for
wages and so on it's like you know the
capitalist one just wanted to make sure
that people in their system thought they
were living in the better system and so
it's interesting yeah yeah
I just want to tear expanding on that
slightly and we had a movement in the
late 80s which was social Europe where
the European project moved to being very
much just an economic project or social
project and that was also when the the
right-wing movement started to kick back
and it was usual and I'm interested in
how you beat the money that is linking
together the extreme end of capitalism
and the extreme end of the victims of
capitalism and what how you break that
link because those to me seem to be the
two pieces to two groups most involved
in being emotionally invested in brexit
great question well there just is a big
problem that there are two worlds I mean
there are two whole society is in this
country where it was just such an
incredibly steep dropoff I mean the big
surprise to me sort of traveling around
this country is how many places there
are where that just seemed to be in
decline where people's health is in
decline their prospects are in decline
where they don't see a future but they
can't afford to leave because they can't
afford to live in one of the places
where there are jobs and this I think
this was allowed to develop to a very to
a very advanced point before brexit was
even on the table so I think it's taken
on the energy from this shearing off of
one Britain from the other and I think
one way or the other the left and the
right and the centre have to somehow
speak to those people I mean to be
honest like I think the people that went
for breakfast it were also the people
that were damaged by austerity so I
think the right and the left and
overlapping a lot one way or the other
you know their problems have to be
addressed but the social Europe is
actually as a as a slogan as something
that people is something that comes up
like in France that came up a lot as
something that I think people would go
for they just didn't see any hope for it
to happen and what's sort of interesting
there yeah I talked about the sort of
absence of a language of the future and
if you think I don't know if you agree I
mean we're all Europeans sort of but and
you know what unites I always felt the
first time I left Europe was when I was
17 and I went to the United States and I
remember this was sort of I you know I
went to a school there for for a while
and and I remember going to the doctor
for the first time and being asked for a
credit card and I remember I was like
what and and you know and a Swedish
friend was with me and we were both like
what and this idea that you have to pay
for health care and so in other words I
left when I left this continent for the
first time I realized that there's
something that unites us in Europe
beyond our borders that is very powerful
and that is this this idea of a welfare
state and of solidarity and it's sort of
fading unfortunately but it's sort of
been part I would argue of European
identity and and what's sort of sad and
a way to see is that the parties that
embodied this and actually helped build
these systems over you know 150 years
they are dying I mean the social
democracy is dying in Europe right now
and and to me again that's that's sort
of tragic and sad because I feel like
that and embodies a huge part of
European identity but maybe it's also an
opportunity maybe this is the moment
where somebody comes up with the recipe
to embody this again it feels late in
the day but that might be alike there
you might have a language for the future
because people are looking for
protection right and the Nationalists
are saying we'll protect you from
migrants or we'll protect you from like
Brussels but you know if somebody came
along it's
you know we'll protect you from from
inequality and we'll protect your way of
life in a fairer way and actually find
some some good solutions I think that
could resonate so we do number one thank
you so much my name is Erica thank you
also for the daily I'm from the states
obviously and it keeps me grounded in
home everyday so thank you for it thank
you my question really relates what what
you just said I'm a global health
mastery student and I went to a talk
this year with a GP here in the NHS who
had voted for brexit from the left who
was harkening back to that kind of early
welfare state the founding of the NHS
principles of social democracy and
wanting to get back there feeling that
that was what had been lost and I wonder
if you could comment on the kind of
irony of that the longing for a kind of
cohesive we're in this together
state while also being part of a
nationalist kind of separatist movement
in a way and maybe even in in kind of
relation to president Trump's recent
comment that he walked back that I'm not
convinced he actually walked back about
the NHS being on the table in a
potential trade deal with the US what
that means for the irony of trying to
leave something that was perceived as
undemocratic in the EU and landing in
the lab at transnational corporations
which are the least democratic things in
the world question we're gonna do one
more question after this as I know we're
getting to the end of our thing but well
it is certain go turbo that the NHS
brought a screeching halt to what
appeared to be almost universal welcome
for for Trump and I do think when people
are brought face to face with what it
would mean to have a release of drug
prices basically we pay ten times twenty
times as much for the same drugs in
America as Britain's do for their drugs
because they bargain for mass purchases
so I think when people realize what its
gonna mean I think that actually can
move the dial a little bit and then as
far as social welfare it's notable than
in the Nordic countries a lot of the
anti-immigrant parties are left-wing and
what they are all about is protecting
the welfare state by shutting the doors
and
making sure that people who are gonna
demand too much for the welfare state
aren't aren't allowed in the country so
I think you know that's a place where it
goes from the right to the left pretty
easily so we're gonna do one more
because we've reached our magic hour of
8:30 so all right the eagerness yeah
don't fall
make it count
I actually have two questions one that's
really bothering me so I'm German and
I'm living in London so I have kind of a
connection I'm I'm a deeply convinced
European and one argument I'm always
missing is how much and the individual
profits from the European Union we have
three individual profits from the
European Union the only reason we have
such a high level of consumer protection
is actually because of the European
Union the amount of like health care we
have the amount of protection against
competition law is all due to the
European Union and I think in all these
nationalistic new movements there's a
problem with marketing in the European
Union they don't explain to the
individual enough how much they do
that's my perspective and so that's one
that's kind of the question how you
perceive that during your journey and
the second one is everyone is building
at blocks now so we have the United
States that's kind of blocking from the
entire world unfortunately we have China
we have Russia and where do we see
ourselves in 30 years if we as the
European Union are not sticking together
because I feel like in 30 years Russia
will not ring Luxembourg and ask for
their opinion might possibly there will
also not ring Germany anymore but I'm
just wondering like where's the Tudor
perspective if we don't stick together
now what are we gonna be as as 28
European states and I like your question
because it's like we haven't talked
about the EU as an entity is it just a
terrible conveyor of its own message I
mean Roger Cohen one of our great
columnist once described Europe as like
the world's most poorly marketed miracle
and I thought he kind of nailed it
I think you're right I think you're
probably still if I may speak from a
position of privilege and this is again
something you know SMI and I felt
humbled on my trip because I realized my
assumption because I was talking to
these young I was like but you can just
travel you don't need to show your
passport and you don't need to change
your money and you can go and study and
you can do Erasmus and they're not doing
any of these things because they're
actually so limited and beyond a certain
income and it's not just the destitute
it's actually a sort of a lower working
class and they they have advantages no
doubt on some level but in terms of the
concrete benefits that we see very
regularly they don't see them sure no
one after I've discussed with many
people and no one has ever said that's
wrong is online shopping we do we
conclude valid contracts everyone does
like no matter what you vote or whether
you actually vote you conclude a valid
contract on the internet and you can
just resign from that contract because
of EU competition law that is so amazing
to me and that's like and you can send
you away and everyone like every
eighteen-year-old in France Italy can
listen but if you have two euros to cook
a meal for a family of five that doesn't
matter
but I think that a lot of people are
confusing but what kind of the European
Union as a political concept with what
the economy we opted for also does and
the financial crisis in 2008 yeah and I
think you're right and I think we can
all agree that there have been a whole
range of advantages that have been
brought about by the European Union the
problem is that on some of the big
questions
it has disproportionately benefit
benefited those with privilege and
disproportionate levels without
privilege and that needs addressing and
it's not just the EU but it's democracy
it's all these big things just quickly
on the block thing
I mean you are absolutely right and I
think if this is something for most on
a lot of politicians minds I mean Angela
Merkel this is her big thing like you
know the world order is breaking apart
we can't rely on America anymore and not
it's not just about trumpets it's sort
of structurally things are shifting
America is focused on China
transatlantic relations aren't gonna go
back to what they were you know Europe
needs to stand on its own feet and it
needs to work together if it wants to
matter in the world Russia just as much
much as Trump wants to destroy the
European Union and all these far-right
movements are sort of little fist
columns for Russia with the exception of
some of the Eastern European ones that
don't like Russia very much for obvious
reasons but you know the Italians the
French the even Orban I mean you know
they they very have closely cooperate
with Russia so you know and I heard an
interesting and scary story recently
about China you know having invested
very very heavily in Greece on the back
of this this sort of you know desperate
austerity that caused so much social and
human pain in Greece after the financial
crisis or the economic crisis there and
now it's sort of almost dictating how
Greece votes on certain European issues
so they I don't want to overstate it but
there's a sort of sense that China might
have a proxy vote and the EU via Greece
I mean meanwhile Russia is coming in and
being very close to some of these
far-right parties so your point is
absolutely right and it feels again very
late in the day to be seriously talking
about this issue I don't think it's too
late by the way one guy and this
question was asked earlier I feel like I
answered it poorly about who you should
follow like the good ideas and so on I'm
gonna come and talk to you at the
reception but there's one other guy I
recommend and I'll think of some woman -
Timothy Snyder is great and you have you
know I'm sure there's stuff online and
speed he recently spoke in Oxford and
he's he's spoken up a lot about Europe
and he is much more upbeat and about the
sort of the opportunity for Europe to
find that language of the future and
have a plan whether it's on an on a sort
of social democratic
idea of wealth redistribution
redistributing not just wealth but also
respect right and and sort of attention
and also about just sort of standing
your ground having you a vision for the
future in a world where America is kind
of looking back it's sort of a weird
nostalgia nationalism something and then
there is China which is you know full
power ahead with very much a vision for
the future yeah so basically let me sum
this up my thank you I think there's a
big political space up for grabs there
you know the simple fact that Europeans
don't want to leave the EU but they
really don't like it shows there is this
is up for grabs in space and it's it's
the jury's still out but I think the
next few years will be pretty decisive
and I think the next five days of the
daily are gonna tell a remarkable story
I think you're getting a little bit of a
sense of the kind of talent that we're
working with here I really want to thank
you all for coming out I want to thank
you for supporting and listening to the
daily and supporting and hopefully
subscribing to the New York Times and
for giving us your time your empathy and
your intelligence we are so so grateful
so thank you all very much
of you
[Applause]
[Music]
and it wouldn't it wouldn't be proper if
I didn't sign off
I'm Michael barber oh I will see you on
Monday
[Applause]
you